[Musique]
le discours du président sur l'état de
l'union c'est en fait le programme de
l'année en cours qui prononçait devant
les deux chambres du congrès en vertu de
la section 3 de la constitution
américaine
le président doit informer de temps en
temps le congrès de ses priorités et de
l'état du pays depuis les années 1930
cet événement solennel a lieu une fois
par année
fin janvier ou début février c'est un
moment particulier car il permet au
président de rassembler sous le même
toit
les trois branches du gouvernement le
législatif avec les sénateurs et
représentants l'exécutif avec le
président et son cabinet ainsi que le
judiciaire avec elle juge de la cour
suprême
georgia chine tient évidemment le
premier président à livrer ce message en
1790 à new york la capitale de l'époque
parfois les vrais sous la forme de
discours écrit ce message a surtout été
énoncée en personne par les présidents
l'avènement de la radio de la télévision
et de l'internet a permis au numéro un
américain qui se sont succédé de
publiciser davantage leurs priorités
depuis 1966 le discours est suivi d'une
réplique de l'opposition
[Musique]